So we have this initiation set.
So that's places where it's, let's say,
legally reasonable to actually execute
this option or this abstract action.
Similarly, we have termination sets.
And a termination set is not the set
of states where an option may be ended,
it's actually a generalization of that.
It's a set of probabilities.
So, it maps states to a number,
which is the probability that
the option will end in that state,
or can end that state.
>> I think that makes it sense.
So they're both they're
both kind of sets but
this is kind of a more
soft general kind of set.
And is it saying that no matter what,
when the option gets to one of those
termination states a coin is flipped,
and if it comes up heads
then the option's done?
>> I think from the point of view of the
person sitting outside the option, yes.
Inside the option it's
not quite done that way.
It's not like the option is running and
it's always flipping a coin.
This is more sort of a a way of
describing the fact that something
can end in a particular state.
Now, of course, you could turn this
into a set by putting a probability of
0 over all the states,
where you don't want it end and
having a probability of 1 exactly
where you want it to end.
>> I see, so that's a sense in which
it's a generalization of that idea?
>> Right, exactly.
But basically, I'm going to execute this
action starting from one of the states
in set I.
And it's going to run and
it will in end up in some state
when the option terminates.
And this gives me a probability
of it being in one particular
state or the other.
So all an action is, is it's,
well you're in a state,
you take an action and
you end up in another state.
But since we're talking about
these temporally abstract options,
things that happen over time,
we need to know what's happening
inside the option while it's running.
And we already have a term for that.
It's called a policy.
So, here we have a generalization
of the way we've been talking about
policies in a way.
Within an option of policy is more than
just a mapping from states to action.
Here, it's a probability of being in
a state and taking a particular action.
But again,
we could turn that into a normal policy,
as we've mostly been talking about it,
by just having a probability of 1 over
the action that we're going to take.
And 0 zero over everything else.
And then it is just a direct simple
mapping from state to action.
>> Like a deterministic
Markov memoryless policy?
>> Thingamajiggy, yes, exactly right.
But, anyway, this is a formalism, but
I think it sort of is just trying to
capture this idea of, as you say, kind
of a procedure or a function that runs.
There are places where you
can execute the function.
There are states where you'll end up
after you've executed the function.
And there are things that
are happening inside the function.
The code itself is the policy.
It's the actions that you're going to
take in the states that
you're going to see.
>> Hm, okay.
>> Okay, so
let's see what we can do with that.